speaking of Disney The Daily wire are
going to do that on version of Snow
White with Brett Cooper starring as Snow
White I saw that I saw that I mean that
to me is you know largely a uh
declarative statement of culture war on
what's happening with children with
children's movies you know it's
synthesizing down all of the little
tangential issues that have been
included is it anything to do with the
push toward the sort of books that are
in school is it us you know denying this
uh Rachel Ziggler Zigler throwing Snow
White under the bus like she doesn't
have a prince charming she has a stalker
we don't need that what do you think
about
that I think that it is a very dangerous
lesson to teach young girls that boys
that show interest in them are dangerous
and to be avoided I think it makes for a
generation of fragile narcissistic
fearful young girls that I wouldn't want
as a daughter and that I don't want as a
mother you know what a perfect example
that
is the movement of feminism is the
ultimate example of not choosing your
enemies
wisely you chose men as being the enemy
40 years later 50 years later you're 65
years old single not married no kids
you're living in an apartment or a condo
with a dog or a cat that that's all you
ever talk about and you're lonely and
you're sitting there saying I was wrong
men are not the enemy but guess what
that movement stole 50 years of your
life you know how painful that is what
what she's doing right now with the
messaging she's giving and then getting
out there and saying well I don't want
to be able to have to do this no you
know what the it's not necessarily going
to be that way nowadays you know women
don't need that anymore it's a complete
different era right now we're talking
about and to do this at a hundredy year
anniversary of Disney yeah really with
what Walt and many of us I remember
living in Iran watching Disney cartoons
translated in farsy literally in farsy
it it's it's very weird when you watch
it in farsy cuz the language is a rough
language you know you get you watch
Pinocchio and farsy it's not as
appealing right but we grew up with this
stuff you know we grew up with watching
these cartoons to see that taking place
is uh if you ask me it's absolutely
pathetic but you're seeing how many back
to back to back flops Disney has right
now yeah and it's not a good look by the
way the buyers who want to buy Disney
they're loving this Apple's one of the
most qualified buyers they they hope
Disney makes five more flops Apple
sitting there saying make five more
flops Iger please by the
way have you read the right of a
Lifetime by Bob AER okay another
interesting guy what he did with his
38th career at ABC obviously he's been
there a lot longer but when you read the
book the first 38
run to be one of the best power Brokers
than to finish your career up the way
you're doing right now very very bad way
of finishing it up he's not an idiot
right you don't have the excuse of not
knowing he is for sure what a point you
just made he is 100% not an idiot this
guy was about to run for president Bob
Iger was going to he was one of the guys
that everybody was trying to get to run
for president him and Oprah they were
supposed to be this literally this was
the conversation so he also ended up
choosing the wrong enemies and the wrong
allies not realizing your best allies
are parents you're losing parents who
have been watching this for years you're
losing the people that this is a legacy
product it's another example of a
complete screwup that's going to come
out of discount for somebody else like
apple I mean look at to go back to Ben
and what Jeremy are doing over the daily
wire uh Hershey's do a campaign that
they don't like within five days they've
released their own chocolate bar uh that
shaving company does something they
don't like within 24 hours maybe they
filmed a video with a McLaren for
Jeremy's razors they don't like the way
fantastic commercial by the way well
done Jeremy's got Jeremy's got skills I
listen to him and Shapiro talking about
the fact that originally Jeremy was the
talent
and Ben was the money man and the the
the uh data guy behind the scenes do you
know Zack Levi I think his name is Zack
Levi the actor who played the uh what is
the movie the the the the the superhero
for kid movies what is the guy's name
Ben what is it Ben no it's you're the
one with like yeah four kids yeah trust
me I've seen this movie a couple times
he he played Kurt Warner a recent movie
that came out the American Underdog he
played Kurt Warner him
and Jeremy used to have a production
company apparently 10 15 years ago and
Zack ended up being a big time actor in
Hollywood doing very good for himself
and by the way Jeremy is another great
example of a guy that's got enemies just
look at his eyes when you talk when you
hear Jeremy speak you you see the fire
built for enemies he's got enemies and
he wants to take those enemies out but
that's why I thought the daily y was an
illustrative example because they are as
far as I can see largely a company built
on identifying enemies
you know they're very much in opposition
to ideas that they don't like to
movements they don't like to people that
they don't like and uh yeah man I mean
it's you have to be built for that you
really really do need to be built for it
and it certainly seems to me that what
Ben and what Jeremy are doing over there
is purpose built to be the anti this the
anti that and a lot of the time it's new
movements that they don't just they
don't agree with the Market's going to
prove if the concept is going to work or
not and if it can sustain because if
it's a built to Salt concept they're
going to be they're going to succeed but
can somebody else come and pick up that
concept and continue with that with the
same level of fire it's going to take a
couple decades to figure that part out
it's interesting to think you know from
from our side when you see those Rachel
Ziggler interviews and she's saying
courting is stalking um a girl doesn't
need to be saved by a prince you know
she's busy thinking about how she can
fulfill her own dreams and becoming the
woman that she always knew that she
could and so forth you think a lot of
people are is that really the you know
the highest manifestation Is that real
self-actualization for young women
nowadays that's the question they ask
and you're totally right that look
ultimately the market will choose
there's no question about it the market
will choose the market is brutal you
know you know what's the great thing
about it's always right it's always
right you know you can you can say well
let me tell you I'm the best bodybuilder
in the world yeah okay look at your CES
yeah good luck to you go put those
little skimpy you know uh shorts on and
see what your you know legs look like no
you're not as good as you think you are
you're full of it yeah Market is brutal
podcast business Concepts Investments
drinks you know alcohol books you write
when we first wrote uh when I first
wrote your next five moves and we
launched it August of 2020 this is
during the peak of coid my publisher
Simon and Scher ask and says so how do
you think the book's going to do how you
going to judge the book me and Greg
dinkin are talking I said if the book is
doing well 3 years from now it was a
good book you can have a great marketing
campaign the book does well the first 30
60 90 days but is the book selling three
years later if it is that's a great book
because a market will tell you that
we'll get back to talking to Patrick in
one minute but first I need to tell you
about
element element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
junk no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other BS it is a
healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks and it's how I
started my morning every single day for
over 3 years now you don't need coffee
first thing in the morning your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't even active for the first 90
minutes of the day but your adrenal
system is and salt acts on your adrenal
system best of all they have a nobs no
questions asked refund policy where you
can buy it and try it completely
risk-free and if you do not like it for
any reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box right now you can get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box by going to the link in
the description below or heading to
drink LM nt.com slod wisdom that's drink
LM nt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Patrick then press here for the full
length over 2hour long podcast go on
give it a
press